hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 7 video
totally great lead-in to what's gonna be
a crazy finale I was a little surprised
where they left each of the groups in
terms of dramatic tension most of my
focus is on Rick's group right now but
there's still some big stuff that could
happen with the other two groups all the
characters got at least one really good
moment and we probably saw what was the
best improvised Walker weapon all season
long
real quick heads up new round of the
giveaway starts now it's just a $20
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video super simple so
careful for spoilers in case you haven't
seen the episode yet starting with top
five moments number five Karl vs.
Gabriel you could also call this Gabriel
vs. everyone left at the church
Gabriel vs. Judith that's actually a
nice thought he's so scared of
everything he probably is scared of that
little baby too if you were a little
confused obviously he couldn't kill that
Walker at the end because he saw the
cross I'm guessing the deep prolly knew
that person to that woman but it looks
like he turned around and went back to
the church he's such a coward I wouldn't
be surprised if he didn't have the
courage to go out on his own I haven't
heard anything about Seth Gilliam
leaving the show or not coming back for
the second half of the season so I don't
know if he'll survive or if something
big is gonna happen I don't think that
they're gonna let the finale go by
without something crazy going on at the
church there's really the three
different groups at this point we have
Rick's group where the main action is
gonna be then we have Carl Michonne
Judith and Gabriel and then we have
Abraham's group which is now kind of
like Maggie's group hands down favorite
moment was Carl murder splaining how to
push a machete through someone's skull
sometimes they're not as soft as the
other ones I would say of all the people
he probably has more sense than most I
mean he's probably pretty messed up a
little a kid I mean I see him snapping
at some point like father like son but
for now he seems pretty solid there was
a brief moment when I was proud of
Gabriel for fighting that Walker off but
then he went back to old Gabriel when he
couldn't kill her he just seems like the
kind of person who has suicide written
all over his face he is totally gonna
burn in hell no matter what so I don't
think that committing suicide would
leave him off any worse it was kind of
funny to see them ripping down his
church though it was like they were
ripping down his faith or his sanity
which I guess are kind of the same thing
number four Abraham's
picks up the pieces actually this should
be Abraham's group becomes Maggie's
group or Gone Fishing there was the big
WTF mullet lies reveal last episode so I
can understand why they made this story
a little bit more hopeful but I don't
think they would allow things to
continue through the finale without
something crazy happening with that
group and we saw that sign at the end
buckle up it's the law I'm wondering
what that means sometimes when I see
things like that I think they're
referring to other parts of the story
like they're talking about the officers
or they're talking to the audience like
we need to buckle up because the story's
gonna get freakin crazy I think that
there's a literal interpretation to that
I don't think it's all metaphor thinking
about a little bit more - now I'm
actually wondering if they're just gonna
try and crash that firetruck through all
those Walker's like that's why they need
to buckle up it was really nice to get
Rosita's backstory - I feel like it's a
good moral tale for telling people that
you think that they're important it's
funny that she said that Abraham was the
first person to tell her he needed her
now that that's gone to [ __ ] Glen's
picked up the slack she and Eugene will
both be useful in whatever new situation
they find themselves in Tara of course
totally amazing his comedic relief
fist-bump it tattoo it on your fist then
bump it she's like the self-appointed
morale officer now I feel like she's
actually come a long way since season
four Tara
I don't know that she's completely
forgiven herself but I think all this
trouble with Eugene has taken her mind
off of it she seems pretty well-adjusted
usually it's people like Sasha the
people that are dealing with really
crazy stuff that you need to watch out
for they're the ones that make terrible
decisions
speaking of which Abraham looks like
he's slowly coming to but his hand
didn't you see when he picked that water
bottle up he uses messed-up hand they
keep showing that hand I feel like
something crazy is gonna happen with
that at some point we can just think of
the hand as like the red herring right
now or like the ginger herring I guess
number three Beth saves Carol any time
they give weaker characters big hero
arcs I get a little bit nervous because
it could be foreshadowing for something
really terrible happening I haven't seen
any overt spoilers about characters
dying but all the theories are on Carol
and Beth right now so I feel like
everyone is watching their scenes extra
careful just to see if there's any
potential clues which is all over now
because we finally got the teaser for
the next episode and that's it there's
nothing left in terms of character
development
I feel like Beth has grown quite a bit
at the
she is strong I mean she was strong
before she just proved it dawn the whole
scene with her working the grift totally
hilarious it's like orange is the new
black Walking Dead edition she's like
the taylor schilling of Walking Dead now
don't you feel like Walking Dead what it
turned into orange is the new black just
a little bit of theta stayed at the
prison that actually been a pretty funny
show to watch
I mean Walking Dead isn't meant to be a
funny show but you do get really
hilarious moments number two Rick's
group captures the police officers so
the title of the episode is crossed as
in you have crossed the line that
usually tells you who the villains are
like the people who go crazy right now
though that seems like Rick and the
survivors mostly just raked though he
just has murder written all over his
face
I just I love the way that they flip
things in this episode it made the
police officers seem like the voice of
reason and Rick seemed like the crazy
man that's gonna be really important for
the finale like they're really trying to
present both these groups as fairly
equal like Brendan situation we're
trying to make the best of it let's try
and do this the right way so we can all
walk away and sleep in our own beds
tonight some of my favorite scenes from
this whole storyline Daryl's improvised
Walker weapon totally amazing totally
disgusting at the same time he basically
grabbed it like a bowling ball if you've
ever seen Mystery Men Janeane Garofalo
has this bowling ball with a skull
inside it it just reminded me of that a
little bit all those walkers that they
had littered in that area they were
calling rotters but really they were all
melting and if you were confused as to
why they were so melted it was just the
heat from the Sun that was why Maggie
put the covering over a Eugene just so
that he wouldn't get super sunburned
just think of it as a PSA for using
sunblock even though we aren't nowhere
near beach season Sasha and Tyreese also
totally touching moment I love the way
they panned out though to all the
walkers and it went from like really
touching hug to super gross touching hug
it's just like The Walking Dead you know
to give you this really tender moment
and then pan over to someone rotting in
the street just like yeah that makes you
feel good inside really good right in
here and my number one WTF moment police
officer totally pulls a fast one on
Sasha and gets away just to be clear
before the [ __ ] went down I think there
was a chance that their plan could have
worked like the compromise now though
they still have two police officers but
the one police officer is gonna get back
and inform the hospital what's going on
so they can prepare like they can
prepare their defenses
they've taken away the element of
surprise like that was what Rick was
depending on really the whole thing is
like Rick's plan versus everyone else's
plan Rick is like I want to go in and
shoot everyone and everyone else
his group as well as the police officers
they're veritable enemies say no no we
can totally do this another way
especially Daryl even though he's super
pissed about losing Carol he's still the
same character that he was in the last
episode the one that pulled Carol back
from doing the same type of thing that
Rick is getting ready to do how our
little darrell has become a man
Karla's kind of on the same mark - it's
like the South Park situation where the
adults are being crazy and the young
people are the sane ones I will say I'm
happy Sasha didn't get pushed out that
window I thought that that was what was
gonna happen whenever he walked up
behind her I knew he was totally gonna
pull a fast one I just didn't know if he
was gonna knock her out or push her
right off the ledge there are definitely
a few characters I don't think are gonna
die in the finale the weird thing about
predicting Walking Dead this is is that
it seemed like over the last five years
the show wants to keep as many people as
possible like the more people it keeps
the more stories it can tell the easier
it is to prolong the show
speaking of deaths I feel like Beth and
Carol are still at the top of the hit
list
Emily Kenny's been posting so much of
her music stuff that it makes me feel
weird it's like yeah they're getting
ready to go on winter break so all the
actors are gonna have extra time to do
whatever they do whenever they're not
doing Walking Dead but you always wonder
you're like hmm maybe she's preparing
for another career breaking the two
though I still feel like Carol is higher
on the hit list than Beth is like if
anyone's gonna go I feel like the best
chance is on Carol just because she's so
incapacitated right now it's not like
she's gonna wake up and just go apeshit
on everyone knowing Carol that might not
stop her from trying which actually be
pretty interesting to watch if she's
gonna take anyone out I would love to
see her take out that crazy doctor maybe
some of his gerbils to maybe take him
out with a gerbil that would be great
that's actually a thought using a gerbil
as an improvised weapon that's actually
really good jumping off points so what
was your favorite moment in the episode
and let me know here's my big question
for you what's the next improvised
weapon you want to see on the show
personally I really just want to see a
gerbil used as a weapon like either have
Beth or someone just shove one down
someone's throat overall I gave the
episode a solid b-plus I totally love
the attention that they're building in
Atlanta but I felt like they kind of
dropped the ball in the other areas it's
like there's no way that Abraham's
driving that firetruck through a bunch
of walkers is gonna be as crazy as
what's gonna go down at the hospital and
who knows what's gonna happen back at
the church I feel like of all the things
they could do with Karl's group to match
the tension or the energy of the other
groups would be to have Gabriel just
totally smashed someone up like a walker
or some intruder there's been no signs
that that's gonna happen either Gabriel
is going to have some sort of hero
moment or Carlos just gonna straight-up
kill him really his only purpose on the
show right now has been as a improvised
innkeeper for the survivors and they're
already tearing down the inn Carla said
it himself you can't stay in one place
for too long anymore
meaning that they're not gonna be there
in the second half of the season
so either Gabriel's gonna have to man up
and go with them or he's gonna have to
die irregardless he cannot stay at that
church I'm totally a fan of Seth Gilliam
as an actor but I feel like his
character just has not been serviced
really well this season so far he is a
big character in the comics it's totally
possible they could take him that route
usually when new actors are signed to
The Walking Dead
they have options in their contract in
case the producers want to use them
later like when people are brought on as
guest stars in season five sometimes
they have options to become regulars in
season six and so on and so on I will
say for all the people that are watching
for behind the scenes picks they're
still filming episodes so you can
actually like see the actors walking
around on sets and doing stuff there are
some things that lead me to believe you
know certain characters that we think
might die are not gonna die
I'll just caution you if you're looking
at those the characters could be on set
for flashback scenes just because
they're on set doesn't mean their
character is still alive all in all
great episode great lead-in to the
finale a lot of questions raised
especially the buckle your seatbelt
thing but again I think they're just
gonna drive that fire truck right
through that herd of walkers they made
it sound like it's gonna be some sort of
slip and slide some sort of gooey
disgusting slip and slide I will try and
do some extra videos I'll definitely be
doing some bonus videos when it's off
the air when it's on break it'll come
back pretty quickly though but feel free
to leave me any requests for special
bonus videos that you really want to see
and be sure to subscribe to get
everything I will continue the giveaway
in the off season don't worry just every
time I post a bonus video I'll just do a
new round of the giveaway just like
normal Q&A tomorrow and in case you
haven't seen me talk about it I have new
Mobile links up here so if you're on
your mobile phone or on a tablet it's
the same links that I add over here so
nice and simple right now click here for
the Q&A I'll add that tomorrow and click
here for last week's episode thank you
so much for watching so let's all
high-five I'll see you guys tomorrow